you mentioned RFK the guy you met what
do you think about uh some of the other
candidates outside of Joe Biden in the
in the Democratic party RFK Jr
what do you think of him as a candidate
I've met him we once had dinner and we
have a number of friends in common which
is what makes this a little more awkward
but I think his campaign is basically
sort of like a chaos candidacy to raise
awareness and maybe raise money either
for his book or his anti-vaccine
organization children's defense fund I
believe it's called I think there's some
reporting that Steve Bannon really liked
the idea of him running as a Democrat
again to just generate chaos
I don't find it super interesting I
don't find it worthy of that much
discussion uh smart guy nice guy
has been doing anti-vaccine work that I
don't find particularly inspiring so
it's not just anti-covered vaccine it's
bro more broader than them he's been in
that space long before the coveted
vaccines yeah yeah I don't find it super
interesting well he also wrote the book
uh
the real Anthony fauci is that the name
of the book did he write that that's
interest I didn't I don't know that's
I'm not sure about that I'm aware of
that book I didn't know he wrote it I
think I did but it's been uh uh it's
been on my reading list to get uh I've
been trying to get a good balanced
reading list about uh the covet pandemic
to understand what the hell happened and
um anytime I start to try to go into
that place it's just I'm exhausted by it
well it's interesting to me that you
wouldn't wait longer before delving into
those books to have maybe a more
clear hindsight
but I think this is a pretty good time
you don't think so like this this is
uh it depends on your goals if you're
thinking of it as a historical event yes
you should probably wait longer but if
you're thinking about like understanding
what is broken about our system that we
responded so poorly
that there was so much division what is
broken about our political system that
um it didn't unite us it divided us
who's to blame there's probably a lot of
different narratives but I feel like the
more you learn about this the the better
you can understand I read um I'm just
Vladimir Putin I read like five
biographies already maybe more
um just it helps to really understand
the people involved the organizations
evolved I don't know everything from the
scientists to the political leaders
um
it felt like the blog posts and the
tweets didn't quite Captivate they
didn't quite no one of the things I read
a ton I don't read any like modern
political books so I don't read the
Memoirs of elected officials I don't
read any I just feel like I get enough
of it in my job so my reading list is
just other things it's history it's
narrative non-fiction economics
Etc and that's my bias because I'm so
overloaded with a lot of the stuff
you're talking about I haven't read any
of Obama's books I didn't read John
Bolton's book or you know I I don't read
any of that stuff although I'm sure
there there is value to be gleaned from
it
what about the other candidate that uh
according to the subreddit and as you
mentioned you've criticized it a little
bit uh Marianne Williamson do you think
what are the pros and cons of horizon
candidate
this is another area where many in my
audience really are angry with me yeah I
don't find her candidacy super
interesting I'll tell you the pros and
the cons as I see them I do think that
we have elected officials in the U.S
particularly presidents from a really
narrow range of backgrounds so it's
lawyers and uh sometimes business people
very very often lawyers I would I think
we would benefit from a much greater
diversity of backgrounds and I once said
and that would include uh people from
education people from the Science World
people with backgrounds maybe running
non-profits Etc now Marianne Williamson
did I guess at one point run some kind
of small non-profit and some in my
audience thought that credential alone
would make me fall head over heels in
love with the idea of a Marianne
candidacy I've interviewed for her it's
just not for me is the way I like to say
it it's the the background of the
woo-woo type stuff is a bit off-putting
to me I understand that someone with
literal Christian Bible beliefs that
also I I don't like maybe I'm more
willing to accept as most of our
presidents of course have had those
views because they're otherwise more
qualified but some of the things that
she says just strike me as I just I just
don't know I'll give you an example
when she was on with Russell Brand she
said there's no such thing as clinical
depression it just means someone in a
clinic told you you have depression
I don't believe that to be the case I
think we have an understanding there's
two types of depression there's like a
genetic predisposition depression
there's like a acute something's
happening in my life temporary
depression okay you know when she was
asked about it recently she said
I didn't mean it I was just trying to
impress Russell Brand
I don't know if I'm more bothered by the
things she first said or by the fact
that she wanted to impress Russell Brand
but it's just like it's just really not
for me and I agree with her on we need
to take the climate more seriously we
need to expand access to hell I I'm with
all of that stuff now I want to say one
other thing about this
anybody who wants to run should run I am
not suggesting there should be an
uncontested primary for Joe Biden
absolutely so you think it should be
contested well what I mean by contested
is so there's two parts to what we mean
by contested will the DNC organize
debates and we'll get that in a second
but should should anybody who's on the
left get out of the way because Joe
Biden is President and he's running for
re-election absolutely not the question
about should there be debates I would
like there to be debates the DNC pretty
clearly isn't going to organize them I
think if you did them you would have to
say at what polling level do you qualify
and I don't know exactly where you put
that number but I think it would be a
great thing to put Joe Biden on a stage
with if you can get what six percent
eight percent I'm not really sure what
the number would be I'm totally all for
that
was a set of candidates at least from my
perspective so weak
do you have do you have an understanding
there's a lot of different answers to
this
one aspect to this which I think is more
of a socio-cultural thing which I've
recently read about to some degree is
the job actually turns off the people
who would be best at it because of what
you need to do to become president
and it includes
all but completely abandoning your
existing day-to-day life job which you
may depend on and family to some degree
it's horribly uh negative as we already
talked about
and at the end of all of that you either
lose and then have to rebuild and maybe
you're not in a position to be able to
do that or you win and then now you've
got four years of being one of the most
hated people no matter how good a job
you do so I think by its nature it turns
off a lot of people that would otherwise
be good
um I also think that there's a lot of
posturing from within the parties about
well you might be good but it's not your
time yet so you should wait and then
let's talk about maybe a senate seat
here and there so it's like it's like a
company essentially and they're figuring
out where they want to place people uh I
think all of these things make it so we
end up with candidates most people
aren't super thrilled with so it's
difficult for somebody who's young or an
outsider to uh
to quickly become a candidate I think
that that's true and I think also in a
lot of ways it's just not I mean would
you want to be president no I mean I
can't be because I wasn't born in the
U.S so it's easy for me to say but
um if everyone says no
then would get the people that we have
no I understand that so I would love to
help somehow
sure and I feel like there's not even a
mechanism for helping except to the
Democratic through the voting process
but I'm just
annoyed how little technology there is
in the whole process how little
Innovation there is in the whole process
all of this the sad thing is this is
written about a lot which is
there's this thing called political
hobbyism
and I think there's a good chance that
some of the people in my audience are
political hobbyists in the sense that
they follow this stuff as entertainment
to some degree and I've written a lot
about how uh I've read a lot and talked
a lot about how okay we vote every two
years or every four years in our local
elections Etc and then we think about
politics all the time Neil Postman wrote
about this in his book amusing ourselves
to death but what are you actually going
to do about the kids Starving in this
country and the nuclear buildup in that
country okay if everybody refocused
their attention on their immediate
communities and that could mean any
number it could mean the town or city
you live in or it might mean
um an athletic club or whatever if
everybody this time they spent on
political hobbyism they moved somewhere
else which might put me out of a job
that's okay I'm willing to lose my job
because I think it would be so
beneficial then our communities would
just be that much better because you can
actually affect change in a much more
tangible way well locally whether it's
obvious people talk about potholes but
other things as well
yeah and I wish our system was more
amenable to that kind of contribution
hopefully through the digital space it
would be
let me ask you about on the Republican
side Ron DeSantis
what do you think of him as a candidate
running against uh Donald Trump I think
in the couple of weeks before our our
discussion today
his campaign which hasn't even started
has sort of started to implode and this
was something that I started thinking
about in September October he really
doesn't seem ready for prime time in the
sense that just being confronted and
confronted is not even the right word
just being asked about
uh some topics he didn't really seem to
want to talk about
he responded in such a sort of
disproportionate unhinged way during his
recent trip to Asia he was asked about
why aren't you or why are you responding
but in this weird way to Trump's attacks
on you and he went into this weird
bobble head thing with a weird smile and
something came out that didn't make any
sense and he sort of got mad at the
reporter and it was just like if you
can't handle that you can't be on a
debate stage with Donald Trump and again
for all my criticisms of trump the guy
gets you on a debate stage he can make
you look pretty silly he was recently
asked about his role at Guantanamo Bay
when he was an officer in I forget which
branch of the Armed Forces and he just
sort of attacked the journalist asking
the question and it just looked very bad
and there are increasingly big
Republican donors who are not fans of
trump and were sort of hoping to put
their eggs in the Rhonda sandis basket
who are saying this guy just doesn't
have what it takes I don't think he can
do it so I don't know if DeSantis will
be able to get away once you're polling
20 something like he is and you haven't
even announced it's very attractive and
he probably to some degree is thinking
if I wait till 2028 I might not have
this opportunity again but Trump's
polling 5253 which means even if
DeSantis gets all of the current
non-trump vote he has to figure out how
to take something more for Trump from
Trump I I just don't know how he does it
first of all the implosion aspect that's
that's part of the process isn't it you
kind of implode a bunch of uh a bunch of
times and then rebuild yourself and
rebuild them because the news cycle kind
of forgets it's possible the problem is
if he the first debate is in August
so that's only a few months away and the
decision is going to be have to be made
pretty soon and unless he can get a new
momentum going uh I just don't know how
he gets what he needs in order to really
have a shot so would anyone else run
against Donald Trump it's very tough
right now I mean there are other people
running there's this guy Vivek ramaswamy
who's running Nikki Haley is running her
campaign basically Dead on Arrival
um Trump actually does better in polls
the more people run when when it's just
him and DeSantis that's the best
scenario for DeSantis it's not great for
to sand this but it's it's uh certainly
better
um but I think the difficulty is this is
a question for Republicans to figure out
the people who rightly recognized in
2016 that this guy is not good for their
party
um still believe this guy's not good for
their party but many of them recognize
that most of the voters are still behind
him
you can always say it's early his
polling doesn't really mean anything
anything could happen something major
would have to happen for Trump to lose
that lead if he got more if he was
arrested two more times and had more
indictments and it just became like this
guy can't even campaign because he's so
busy going from court to court maybe
that would make a difference it's really
tough to imagine